the jurgen experience
so if you're going to put someone on
sort of a preventative protocol for for
covid you would recommend corsetin
and you can get it we just i just bought
some on amazon after you brought it up
because i wasn't taking course attention
yeah
quercetin at what dose well what we
started off just for you know
for daily use because the benefit of
quercetin is it drops the inflammatory
cytokines
it increases mitochondria so you produce
more cells so you produce more energy
atp
that was what we were using for and it
was 500 milligrams twice a day
and zinc was 15 to 30 milligrams twice a
day and in the past
20 years i've been sick 13 days and what
i started seeing in our population
because we do a monthly questionnaire to
our patient population and we have two
questions about allergies and about
infections or colds and we started
seeing years ago that the number of
colds people were having were dropping
and their allergies were improving
and honestly i didn't understand why
until covet and start looking at how the
immune system is influenced by things
like
zinc
and certain of testosterone testosterone
stimulates the
cd4 cd8 cells which are the immune cells
that help to defend us against
infections viral bacterial innate
immunity
as well as it increases uh something
called interleukin-10 which is an
anti-inflammatory
product and it drops the inflammatory
interleukins these are the cytokines or
produced by our immune system to help
fight off infections by sending out an
attack against them which is a
biochemical attack other than just
antibodies
so you've got zinc 15 to 30 milligrams
twice a day quercetin 500 milligrams
twice a day that's preventive
treatment and we've had to treat
patients outside of our practice is a
thousand milligrams twice a day with 30
milligrams a thousand milligrams twice a
day of quercetin and 30 milligrams twice
a day of zinc and this is for someone
that has someone who's active and what
is what's going on with zinc and
quercetin and and covert like how how
does it interact
well
the virus that gets into our cells it
gets into our cells through something
called an ace2 receptor and that's what
the um vaccine is fighting against they
call it the spike protein so on the
outer membrane of the virus are these
spikes
so
it uses our own system to transport the
virus into the cell once it's in the
cell the virus releases something called
replicase
replicase is a dna reverse transcriptase
protein that takes over our
manufacturing at the ribosome to make
more viral genome
well it turns out that the
replicase has an area on it that if zinc
attaches to it shuts it off
so quercetin is called an ionophore it
carries charged particles into the cell
otherwise zinc sits outside the cell so
zinc without a zinophore is that a
saline ionophore ionophore io yes i
think without an
it just it doesn't work correct
interesting it's a lot of these people
that are just taking zinc on its own it
doesn't get something all right it
doesn't go into this yeah generally
speaking it won't get into the cell at a
high rate it will over time get in
because we have things that we take in
like
bismuth in our system from fruits and
vegetables we have egcg from green tea
if people are drinking green tea
we've got curcumin from food that's why
in india they don't get it so they're
getting some form of anaphor but if you
want to really
jam the zinc into the cells um use a
corsetin or
turmeric or and then move on to d3
i'm taking 000 ius a day what do you
i personally take a little bit more than
that how much you take
50 000. jesus christ mondays and 10 or
20 000 on every other day
that's a lot why
i don't know yeah that's right
most people say i don't know is there
any negative aspect
yeah there are negative aspects to high
levels of vitamin d but not due to
vitamin d due to what it does
what vitamin d does as i said earlier is
it brings calcium in from your nutrition
and takes phosphorus in so it can build
bone calcium if it's too high
hyperkalemia will cause
the
nausea vomiting and can cause
irregularity of the heart
so if you're taking high dosing of
calcium for whatever reason and you take
high dosing of vitamin d you would be at
risk for developing nausea vomiting and
toxicity a study that was done which is
also on the paper i gave you
they did 113 000 hospitalized people and
they looked at their vitamin d levels
they all had been taking vitamin d they
only found i think it was four people
who had toxicity from elevated levels of
vitamin d and it turned out it was the
liquid form of vitamin d that created
the problem so from that standpoint
vitamin d is very safe and i'm talking
up numbers that are 60 to 100. i try to
keep my range at 80 to 100 because of
studies that are showing you take
calcium no you don't
i have to my nutrition and i monitor my
calcium every six months of my blood
work so if my levels are where they
should be
i'm fine okay so what do you look for in
nutrition to get your calcium from what
are you getting from um you know i eat
cheese i my daughter pulled me off of
cow's milk and tried me on uh goat
cheese
goat cheese she gives me all that stuff
so um in my cheese i get it and then you
know there are foods that i eat i chew
on bones so i get a little calcium that
way chew on bones no i'm just kidding
but
um because i take bone meal yeah yeah
yeah allison makes uh uh bone broth
yeah she makes bone broth at home so it
has
good bone marrow you know protein and uh
some calcium i don't know how much
calcium you get from it
but i monitor i'm getting it someplace
in my nutrition so for someone who has
osteoporosis let's let's look at point
to them they're uh recommended to take
calcium right correct now they're taking
calcium and they have vitamin d3 correct
then they must be careful about what the
levels of vitamin d3 they take correct
and the what do you recommend to someone
who's taking calcium like what what
levels
see
i use the science i use the laboratory
to tell me how much you know i get
ridiculed by my colleagues because i'm
giving everybody a baseline of 10 000
units and they say oh that's toxic it's
going to go pro you go and do the blood
test and you see giving them 10 000 they
get a you know still sub-optimal level
of vitamin d it's because they're not
absorbing it
so i can't assume that ten thousand is
going to give them toxic levels you know
calcium absorption so i i start at uh
five to ten thousand ten thousand seems
to be the amount and then their calcium
they get they have a
a prescribed product which has calcium
and vitamin d in a balanced
combination already so
um who makes that i don't remember which
pharmaceutical i don't use it
you know it's right what's the issue
with the liquid vitamin d yeah the only
thing is with liquid vitamins yeah but
why you think because the absorption
rate
because it gets absorbed so well capsule
encapsulated you know it's fat soluble
you take it after a meal it gets
absorbed and based upon how good the gut
is you know dysbiosis it will regulate
how you absorb it so i don't assume
anything i'll put a patient on a
protocol and then three months later
i'll go and test them and see where
their levels are at if they're at a
great level on that amount that's
perfect for them
how do i know that whatever i'm giving
them is going to be too much too little
or perfect and then the level of
absorption which will indicate in their
blood will will indicate like what
levels are shown in the blood is
directly related to their diet as well
correct and the other nutrients are
taken it's related to
the status of their gut the lining of
their gut it's relative to if they took
it before food or during food with food
it's a fat soluble fat soluble vitamins
like vitamin e um vitamin d or hormone
d
uh
or dhea they all need um food to
optimize the absorption
okay so so we got d3
uh which you take at very high levels
but
what do you recommend 10 000
um you need to have a blood test before
we put anybody on vitamin d we don't
just abstractly you know put them on a
number right we check their levels and
i've been absolutely amazed at not only
the frequency of deficiency of vitamin d
but the fact that i've got surfers
who have deficiency of vitamin d how can
you be a surfer out there in the sun
and be vitamin d deficient wetsuits
right well
they wear maybe the top but their arms
and legs below the belly is exposed
four hours
i'd see a lot of guys with full wetsuits
out there because that [ __ ] pacific
ocean it's cold [ __ ] it's cold it's cold
yeah but when they get out they lay down
on the beach you know
i think human beings need a lot of sun
uh i think that genetics are changing
yeah are they yeah i think so look at
why did we develop this whole system of
vitamin d the vitamin d receptor
stimulates hair growth to cover our body
with hair to avoid the ionizing
radiation that our ancestors
neolithic ancestors used to have they
were getting cancer they were getting
exposed to high levels of because the
air was clear there was no smog back
then so they were getting full strength
of the radiation from the sun and they
were dying so the body is dead smog is
protecting us from cancer uh
is that what you're saying relative
relative to sun
jokes just piece it all together yeah so
hong kong like not hong kong like uh
what what are the chinese cities beijing
beijing
really bad
i would say
yeah i used to work there that's right
the olympics there and they said it was
like the worst air quality we've ever
had for the olympics and the only way
they got the air clear there was
shutting down all the manufacturing
that's in the one of the inner circles
see beijing grew so rapidly that they
have 10 rings around it and i think in
the fourth or fifth ring is where they
have all the manufacturing so when the
financial summit happened they shut them
all down air was clear
absolutely clear the silliest thing i
was there for
new year's one year in february and they
shot off 45 million dollars worth of um
rockets and fireworks and firecrackers
and all that added pollution
you couldn't breathe
and i was on the 27th floor of a
building couldn't breathe up there
really yeah it was pretty bad
pretty bad
so okay so um d3 yes we so we got
quercetin we got uh
zinc 30 milligrams twice a day um or
that's the that's a therapeutic
therapeutic a thousand milligrams twice
a day with 30 twice a day of zinc um
then d3
figure out what the levels are but what
you're taking is somewhere
i i'm taking uh what about uh
120 000 a week if someone doesn't have
like a good place to go they don't they
don't have a good doctor to go how do
they find a doctor that could read their
vitamin levels on on their blood work
like what do you look for like if
someone's listening to this like i
should get my blood work done who do
they go right well functional medicine
is big now and in functional medicine
they're looking at your amino acids
they're looking at your vitamin levels
they're looking at your mineral levels
which need to be done we're not getting
our minerals anymore because we're
getting
bottled water how many minerals are in
here zero of them oh
right zero is well that's hard water
right like well water that's what people
call it
hard water runoff for the mountain i
know but that's what hard water is right
when you get that's high in calcium
hydroxide or calcium oxide whatever it
is calcium
minerals in the water right yeah and uh
you can buy the minerals and put a
couple of drops into the bottle and take
colloidal colloidal that's it
um so you got your d3 you got your
quercetin you got your zinc uh what
about vitamin c
uh vitamin c helps with the immune
system um how much do you take
i don't take uh vitamin c really no what
do you take i have two or three pieces
of citrus fruit that i grow in my
backyard
every morning
every now and then uh allison will bring
in some of the uh from here it's called
strawberry
texas
grapefruits phenomenal sweet as can be a
strawberry grapefruit they call it
strawberry because of the color the
usual one is the
pink grapefruits from texas
not the yellow ones from florida but the
pink ones and they're very high in
vitamin c
also i grow compquats so i'll eat the
whole thing so they have a lot of
natural compounds and i get two cycles a
year so i'm always with natural forms
okay so you just get it i get it all
naturally yeah what other uh some i mean
this is all we're talking about like
during this cohort right pandemic where
everybody's really concerned about their
immune system and protecting themselves
from yeah dhea is also an immune
stimulator dhea you know studies that
came out of massachusetts male aging
study
showed that dhea is extremely important
for protecting the heart
when they looked at you know quartiles
the lowest 25 percent of the range
versus the highest you saw a significant
loss of heart attack deaths and a
significant decrease in hospitalizations
due to heart attack and that's dhea it
also stimulates the immune system so it
up regulates the ability of our system
to defend itself so it's a higher
quality of defense and another issue
with vitamin d
i mean with dhea is dhea is important
for allowing dht
dihydrotestosterone into the cell and
why is that important dht is a byproduct
of testosterone
because it's the combination of dhea
getting dht dihydrotestosterone in the
cell that allows for sugar to be brought
into myocytes into the muscle cells
so there are articles out there talking
about if you want to get the optimal
benefit for muscle growth
you need to make sure your dhea levels
are optimal to get the dht to increase
glycogen in the muscle cells so use that
for energy and for growth
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and audio experience on
spotify you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all for free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes you just need to search
for the jre on your spotify app go to
spotify now to get this full episode of
the joe rogan experience